mais tour des élections régionales qui
ont bien du mal à mobiliser le taux de
participation n'était que de 26% à pena
à 17 heures j'ai entendu le message
porté à l'endroit de nos institutions
par l'abstention impressionnante aux
élections régionales et départementales
70% des gens 66 fautes directes deux
français sur trois sont pas venus voter
il n'y a pas de démocratie sans le
peuple cette désaffection civique
historique constitue un signal majeur
lancé à toute la classe politique et
même à toute la société
[Musique]
et deux
les élections régionales et
départementales de juin 2021 on fait nos
dirigeants l'effet d'une douche glacée
plus des deux tiers des électeurs
français avaient boudé les urnes chaque
leader est venu à la télévision qu'on
fait c'est sa crainte pour l'avenir de
notre démocratie
si décidément le peuple sans détour bien
sûr on était en pleine pandémie et les
électeurs avaient eu peur de se déplacer
mais cela fait maintenant plus de trente
ans que l'abstention aux élections est
en hausse dans notre pays et la nouvelle
montée de l'abstention en 2021 n'a fait
que prolonger les courbes de la chute
inexorable de la participation
électorale depuis la guerre jusqu'aux
années 80 nous avions vécu la période
enchantés de devoir civique avec une
abstention restant aux alentours de 20%
des électeurs inscrits et puis surtout
après la réélection de françois
mitterrand en 1988 les cours n'ont cessé
de grimper bien sûr certaines élections
en ont plus pâti des élections locales
régionales législatives et européennes
beaucoup moins les présidentielles
l'élection présidentielle est tellement
devenue la reine des batailles que bien
des électeurs le sentiment qu'il suffit
de participer à celle mais sommes-nous
comme d'autres pays occidentaux entré
dans une période historique de
démocratie d'abstention le mouvement est
il irréversible est grave pour l'avenir
de notre démocratie
comment y remédier
[Musique]
pour répondre à ces questions nous
allons commencer notre voyage au pays de
l'abstention près de montpellier où
trois amis ont rendez vous pour prendre
un verre et discuter des sujets de
l'heure
c'était le deuxième tour de
présidentielle 2007 en fête 2010 est
étroit
sincèrement c'est la même chose c'était
l'épisode
il fallait voter macron en 2017 et après
j'ai fait j'ai madère fois j'ai voté je
vis et 2017 après j'ai pas voté sur le
rêve parce que bon bah moi si tu veux si
je regarde un petit peu mes frères mes
amis c'est vrai qu'il ya peu de
personnes qui votent mais c'est même pas
pour les excuses de se lever ou de se
déplacer c'est c'est comme je te disais
finalement il ya peu de gens qui se
sentent concernés en fait la personne
qui attend quelque chose de la politique
c'est ce que je sais ils s'adressent pas
à nous et on voit pas comment il
pourrait changer nos vies ont changé la
société dans l'est du tibet à quoi ça
sert que je vote en fait t'as vu le taux
d'abstention record toute erreur non
c'est alors est ce qu'il faudrait pas
plus qu'on s'immisce dans la politique
que ce soit un peu plus participatif
pense que sur des décisions importantes
ce sera intéressant qui nous fasse
participer et le vote électronique censé
lui faire confiance aux gens et on va
trop bien faire les gens se sentiraient
plus concernés les plus concernés ça
fait plus de
confiance en nous mais non en fait y
confiant si tu te sens impliqué bah tu
as envie d'investir tant envie de te
renseigner tu as envie d'aller voter et
tu vas faire l'effort d'aller le
d'immenses à voter sur qui aura le trône
qui aura la place de chacun se bat pour
une place en effet on apprend les débats
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que c'est
ça y est tu as l'impression que c'est à
celui qui va sortir la plus belle mesure
pour conquérir un électorat alors que
c'est parce qu'on veut et c'est ce qu'on
dit à la sortie assorti d'un débat qui
sont dire qu'ici qui a convaincu le plus
offensif qui cyclonique qui a perdu
c'est vrai on est parent devrait dire
c'est qu'il ya eu les meilleures idées
ici calme est revenu pour faire avancer
certains tricks à des idées récents qui
sont fondées qui peuvent être réalisées
par des choses dans le vent voilà nico
tu sais quoi on va voter pour moi se
présenter
[Rires]
nous avons rendez vous avec céline
braconnier professeur de sciences
politiques spécialiste incontesté de
l'abstention qui est aussi la directrice
de sciences po à saint germain en laye
elle est notamment la côte rice d'un
livre de référence sur la démocratie de
l'abstention
sont plus abstentionnistes que la
moyenne les plus jeunes seul facteur le
plus déterminant les plus jeunes d'entre
les citoyens les plus fragiles
économiquement
les moins diplômées également les plus
isolées tous ces facteurs
tiennent éloignés des urnes après un
facteur générationnel et qui est liée en
partie au fait que les personnes qui ont
60 ans aujourd'hui
vous continuez d'aller voter même quand
elles sont sceptiques à l'égard des élus
même quand elle ne croit plus en la
capacité du vote à faire évoluer les
choses elle se rendre aux urnes par
devoir
les plus jeunes sont aujourd'hui très
peu nombreux à continuer de se rendre
aux urnes s'il ne comprennent pas
pourquoi s'ils ne sont pas portés par
une offre électorale qui les intéressent
donc ça on a une vraie réticence des
jeunes à continuer de jouer le jeu de la
participation sans compréhension
continuons l'analyse avec stewart show
de l'institut de sondages viavoice
auteur récent avec frédéric dabi d'un
livre la fracture sur le comportement
politique des 18-30 ans je pense que la
jeunesse elle est frappée par deux
crises
importantes
la première crise et la crise de la
représentativité c'est à dire de cette
difficulté de plus en plus exprimé de
considérer qu'une personne autre que ce
soit puisse représenter son expérience
son avis sa décision à deuxième crise et
je pense la crise politique lire et la
crise du résultat pour la jeunesse alors
là il ya deux est une double logique
d'abord il ya le il ya l'idée du tous
pourris aujourd'hui vous avez 81% des
18-30 ans qui considèrent qu'olive que
le personnel politique est malhonnête et
puis ça joue tous pourris le tous
impuissants
et ce tous impuissance c'est l'idée
selon laquelle alors là soit 82% des
18-30 qui affirment que leur génération
ne croient plus en l'action politique
c'est à dire que l'action politique
c'est un acte vain il ya une vanité du
vote qui s'exprime le politique ne
change plus la vie des gens d'ailleurs
sur toutes les élections intermédiaires
sous la présidence macro son dernier
quinquennat
l'abstention des jeunes a oscillé entre
70 % et 81 2% donc ça montre aussi que
effectivement c'est une c'est un
phénomène abstentionnistes c'est presque
systémique aujourd'hui qui qui qui qui
se diffuse dans la jeunesse
j'ai même pas reçu la carte pour voter
vous on reçoit un truc sinon un courrier
moi j'ai pas
comment faire pour voter il faut en
france obligatoirement procéder à son
inscription plusieurs semaines avant le
scrutin pour avoir la possibilité
d'exercer son droit de vote or
qu'observe-t-on que plus de 13 millions
de personnes sont soit non inscrits sur
les listes électorales soient inscrits
loin de là où elle réside effectivement
le jour du vote et ces personnes là qui
sont mal inscrits s'abstiennent trois
fois plus que celles qui peuvent voter à
côté de chez elle nous rencontrons à
vitry sur seine
quatre jeunes engagés dans le mouvement
associatif
il organise notamment des distributions
de produits alimentaires pour les
personnes démunies
cette année on a dû voter moi par
exemple dans mon entourage que j'ai il
ya très peu de personnes sont parties
voté moi j'ai été pour la première fois
et quand j'en ai quand j'en ai parlé
autour de moi on m'a dit bah ça sert à
rien on fait pareil hélas beaucoup qui
me disent je vois pas l'intérêt de voter
comme ministre délégué à l'intérieur
marlène schiappa s'intéresse
particulièrement au sein du gouvernement
à l'abstention puisque les charges et de
la citoyenneté moi je dirais à des
jeunes qui voient pas l'intérêt de voter
que voter c'est choisir et ce n'est pas
subir et que quand on est mécontent à
des personnes qui sont et maire de notre
ville ou même du gouvernement cet
endroit aussi en démocratie et là on
peut décider d'en changer en allant
voter et de la même manière quand on
veut soutenir un candidat ou une
candidate quand on apprécie son
programme qu'on soutient ce que porte la
personne la manière la vision de cette
personne la seule solution de soutenir
c'est aller voter alors les français se
comment dire
non non de moins en moins peur je dirais
d'exprimer le fait qu'ils n'iront pas
voter je pense qu'il ya une forme de
aussi la de libération de la parole de
dire qu'aujourd'hui on n'ira pas voter
parce que souvent enfin souvent soit
c'est de la résignation soucier de
l'indifférence voire pire ça peut être
aussi un acte être un acte politique
c'est le cas dans beaucoup de d'études
d'opinion qu'on réalise ne pas aller
voter c'est aussi politique mais en
réalité la plupart des abstentionnistes
ne donne pas à leur abstention un sens
politique on s'abstient parce qu'on ne
s'intéresse pas suffisamment à la
campagne parce que on a essayé de
décrypter qu'on ne comprend pas qu'on ne
voit pas pourquoi on se déplacerait
alors qu'on pense que ça n'aura pas
d'effet alors on peut y mettre un peu
donner un sens politique à cette
attitude d'indifférence de retrait mais
voilà ça n'est pas plus que cela cette
crise la représentativité cette crise du
résultat cette vanité du vote cet exil
électoral qui est exprimé par la
jeunesse ne symbolise et ne signifie
surtout pas à mon sens une forme de non
d'intégration civique ou citoyenne
c'est très juste je pense de rappeler
que ce n'est pas parce qu'on ne va pas
voter qu'on ne veut pas ou ne souhaitent
pas participer à la vie démocratique ou
qu'on n'a pas finalement d'engagement
politique si l'abstention était
également répartis dans l'ensemble de la
population elle elle serait moins
problématique au plan démocratique
là ce qui pose question c'est que
lorsque l'abstention est élevé les
votants ne sont pas du tout
représentatif des caractéristiques de la
population générale les votants sont
beaucoup plus âgés beaucoup plus
diplômées beaucoup plus aisé que le les
électeurs potentiels qui ne se déplace
pas avec évidemment des effets des
effets sur les politiques publiques des
effets sur les programmes puisque et
c'est tout à fait logique les candidats
s'adresse en priorité à ceux qui votent
en ce moment moi je me rends compte
peut-être tout 28 les politiques sont
sur tik tok par exemple ne sais pas ce
que c'est pas une façon de le dire ils
comprennent enfin dangereux que bah il
faut agir d'abord à la jeunesse
correctement ils veulent s'adresser aux
jeunes mais je trouve que c'est pas la
bonne manière font en tic tac ok c'est
bien beau fins et fut un temps un peu
les candidats mais
je vais pas voter pour une personne
parce qu'elle m'a fait rire surtout pas
quoi et je trouve que ils ont raison en
soit parce que la plupart ne regarde
plus la télé donc tout ce qui est des
bactéries franchement on n'est pas du
tout au courant alors que maintenant sur
ce secteur qu'on est vraiment bas c'est
vraiment la cible donc là pour passer
des informations et ça c'est vraiment
plus intéressant on présente le tout ce
qui est des textes je regarde jamais
alors que la tuque toc je vois je
découvre des candidats alors que les
avez jamais vu jamais entendu parler
2 2
[Musique]
je crois qu'avec la montée de
l'abstention on peut dire en tout cas
que la démocratie est en panne d'une
certaine manière dans la mesure où on a
élection après élection une grande
partie de la population qui ne souhaite
pas prendre à l'exercice démocratique
qui se met en marche de la démocratie
est donc aujourd'hui la démocratie
l'élection concerne une frange infime de
la population
amélie de montchalin ministre la
transformation et de la fonction
publique elle a notamment créé un site
internet qui tient à jour les réformes
engagées par l'état et surtout leur
degré de réalisation dans chaque
départements du pays
moi je crois que l'abstention d'abord ce
n'est pas une fatalité mais ça doit
obliger les hommes et les femmes
politiques à changer profondément de
pratique c'est de sortir de l'idée
que la politique serait une question de
grands récits de grands concepts de ce
que les français disent souvent
d'ailleurs observer c'est que les
politiques ne parlent pas de sujets qui
les concernent et qu'on arrive à
réancrer notre discours politique mais
surtout notre action politique dans la
vie quotidienne des français je pense
que c'est une énorme alarme et c'est
pour moi pas une fatalité mais sa
demande que collectivement on change la
nature du débat politique
le sénateur françois noël buffet et le
président de la commission des lois du
sénat il a présenté en décembre 2020 un
rapport très détaillé sur le vote à
distance et à par l'élection
présidentielle et l'élection municipale
ils se mobilisent peu et c'est
inquiétant pour notre système
démocratique il n'y a pas dit légitimité
de ceux qui chantent et lui évidemment
mais la base électorale peut apparaître
parfois insuffisante oui je suis inquiet
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un regard très
négatif qui est porté sur la politique
ou plus exactement je dirais qu'en
france les gens aiment la politique il
n'aime pas les responsables politiques
moi je les ai vus parce que je viens de
la société civile j'étais présidente
d'association j'écrivais des livres élu
local pendant plusieurs années quand
j'intervenais dans les médias en tant
que présidente d'association ce que je
disais et est parole d'évangile c'était
très intéressant je n'avais que des
louanges j'étais en gt avec des
commentaires laudatif des articles très
positif sur mon action etc j'ai fait
quasiment la même action mais en étant
ministre en étant membre du gouvernement
et là j'ai pu voir à quelle haine une
partie de la population éprouve pour les
responsables politiques dans leur
ensemble quelle que soit d'ailleurs leur
leur niveau de responsabilité quelle que
soit leur couleur politique
matthieu orphelin et député du
maine-et-loire il a dirigé dans son
département une étude par questionnaire
consacré aux 18-35 ans et la politique
moi je suis un député de terrain
je passe beaucoup de temps avec les gens
écoutent et faire du porte-à-porte à
être interpellé dans la rue les gens ils
ont toujours envie de discuter politique
c'est très rare qu'on se fasse envoyer
balader c'est très très rare donc il ya
ce mouvement très positif de maintenant
ils ont chaque année l'impression d'être
un peu plus mais considéré que l'année
précédente ou parlée par les politiques
c'est un rapport un peu ambivalent mais
ce qu'ils nous disent encore aujourd'hui
c'est la même chose qui nous disait dans
les grands débats après la crise des
gilet jaune et ça s'amplifie
cette déconnexion apparente entre les
responsables politiques et les citoyens
et citoyennes donc on est à un moment je
crois de bascule je crois que c'est
grave parce que c'est une forme de
remise en cause du fonctionnement
démocratique
c'est aussi ce qui donne la légitimité
aux personnes qui sont élus et on voit
bien d'ailleurs chacun est contesté au
nom des élections régionales certains
opposants ont contesté les résultats en
disant que puisqu'on était élu avec 50 %
30 % 20 % parfois du corps électoral
eh bien il n'y avait pas de légitimité à
l'élection c'est grave aussi parce que
ça illustre une forme de de perte de
confiance dans la capacité des élus à
agir à prendre des décisions
il ya donc nécessité de reprendre les
choses en main je sais pas si c'est la
règle qu'il faut changer ou 6 et les
comportements les discours sont aussi
qu'il faut modifier en tous les cas il
ya une forme de désintérêt si ce n'est
des intérêts à une forme de lassitude ou
de de titus de comment dire un peu de
bon sang ça changera rien quoi
bonjour madame bonjour mesdames vous
connaissez ici la maison francs services
de déjà venu et vous y trouver des
choses utiles oui moi je mène depuis que
je suis dans ce ministère un tour de
france qui m'amène tous les vendredis
dans un département différent et je fais
pas la promotion fut pas là pour faire
de la réclame je suis là pour mettre au
fond dans un dialogue d'homme à homme de
femme à femme à porter d'engueulades au
fond sur ce qui a été fait ce qui reste
à faire et si ça reste à faire comment
on peut faire ça accélère le but c'est
plutôt des sympathique et efficace donc
c'est ici de travailler et donc vous
êtes trop et vous je le fais avec les
élus je le fais avec les français je le
fais avec tous ceux et celles qui sont
intéressés par une nouvelle manière de
faire de la politique
moi je pense que c'est intensément les
chiffres qui change tout le temps c'est
pas parce qu'il ya ici qui sont
l'augmentation que pour autant je lis au
quotidien bild et je pense que par ce
biais là on a au fond une action bien
plus fort sur l'abstention que
s'intéresser aux pratiques de vote elle
même qui d'abord nécessite beaucoup de
consensus pour éviter ensuite concret à
la manipulation à la distorsion de voie
à des résultats qui soient pas légitime
moi j'ai été maire pendant vingt ans
dans ma commune j'ai passé beaucoup de
temps beaucoup d'heures aller voir mes
habitants à les intéresser aux sujets à
essayer d'être inventif je dis bien
essayer et inventif et à chaque fois ça
a plutôt fonctionné
ne pas rester dans la routine surtout
pas imaginer participer et une vie
moyens de communication d'aujourd'hui
imaginez des démarches nouvelle débattre
[Musique]
allons à fontenay sous bois avec océane
étudiante qui va avec sa mère retrouvé
une vieille amie de la famille le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'elles ne sont
pas d'accord sur l'abstention
[Musique]
c'est un grand bébé
est né au kenya des campagnes je suis
pas les informations cette fois dans ce
cas qui tint ses repas dans la société
je sais que dans ma fac on est beaucoup
à même passeur qu'elle est un insecte
c'est au bout de cinq ans mais le vote
si tu veux faire changer les choses si
tu veux essayer de participer parce que
c'est le gouvernement qui prend des
décisions
il faut bien que nous on participe aussi
pour dire où soignante à mes côtés ben
notre mécontentement ou faire changer
les lois aussi mon bouygues mais ça si
tu votes pas tu peux rien tu peux rien
faire bouger et même quand tu vas bien
qu'ils aient eu océane 1 voter c'est
donner ton avis etc émettre une opinion
c'est faire partie des possibles ça ne
change rien je te rabot donner son
opinion ça ne changera pas
je sais pas moi je sais qu'avec mes amis
on en dise on n'a même pas parlé des
élections et quand on en parle on prend
souvent la règle à parce qu'on ne sait
pas c'est qu'ils ont sais pas c'est quoi
le programme et le programme façon si
vous votez pour un programme et au final
ce que vous aurez quand la personne sera
élu et ben le trois quarts du temps vous
avez pas ce que vous voulez petit croix
pu non améliorer mais c'est tout le
monde pense comme toi bien évolué qu'est
ce qu'on fait non parce qu'il ya les
générations d'avant qui sont là et qui
ils ont déjà leur vote et vous êtes
beaucoup plus nombreux venu niveau
intellectuel normalement vous devriez
participer et se dire non on va faire
bouger les choses par les urnes en
passant aussi par le côté mais c'est un
seul hic c'est que toi tu pour toi tu
veux faire bouger les choses avec une
urne avec un petit bout de papier sur
laquelle tu vas mettre le nom de
quelqu'un mais c'est important mais
pourquoi mais parce que c'est ta voix
mais ma voix ne compte pas
concours qu'on ait des maillots un
million la voix ne compte pas parce que
ça ne changera rien
mais ça fait 45 ans que c'est comme ça
mais non il ya des petites avancées il
ya des petites en 40 ans des petites
avancées mais juste parce que tu t'es
battu dehors pas parce que tu as voté
débat c'est maintenant faut que tu que
tu participes un petit peu aisément
votants devaient devenir heureuse je
vais mettre mon humeur et là j'ai fait
deux bonnes heures qui va batailler
c'est pas en votant que tu vas devenir
heureuse méthode il a une participation
de
ne pas te laisser des frissons quand tu
en fait voter voter c'est juste pas se
laisser porter c'est à dire que
revendiquer dans la rue c'est très c'est
très bien c'est très beau mais votez
s'est passé ses portes
[Musique]
les etats unis ont longtemps été
considérées comme l'exemple d'une
démocratie d'abstention la moitié des
citoyens boudant les urnes pour la
présidentielle mais ils sont aussi ces
dernières années la preuve que cela peut
changer
nicole bacharan historienne et
politologue spécialiste réputé des états
unis nous explique pourquoi
on vote peuvent aux etats-unis
traditionnellement on vote vraiment peu
ya pas la passion politique que l'on
peut retrouver leur historiquement
historiquement en france alors c'est
vrai que les comparaisons sont parfois
difficiles parce qu'aux états unis on
compte les électeurs potentiels c'est à
dire toutes les personnes de plus de
18 ans ici c'est la base pour calculer
l'abstention mais néanmoins
dans les années 90 2000 on était en
dessous de 50% on accroché à peine 50%
et puis ça a commencé à monter pendant
les années obama 2008 2012 on est
au-dessus de 50% et ça flambe a vraiment
franchi des deux tiers avec les années
trump on peut s'inscrire le jour de
l'élection donc les
modalités d'inscription sont beaucoup
plus souples ce qui fait que réellement
la base c'est le corps électoral les
adultes américains pour calculer la
participation ou d'abstention évidemment
à partir d'obama donc obama puis trump
on est sortis de période où beaucoup
d'américains avaient le sentiment que
c'était assez indifférent si le candidat
x ou le candidat z gagner ça n'allait
pas bouleverser leur vie washington
était loin et le gouverneur de l'état
c'était beaucoup plus proche
la vie privée la vie économique était
plus importante
et au fond que ce soit par exemple al
gore ou george bush en 2000 la
participation était vraiment très basse
pour cause d'indifférence alors c'est
vrai que l'arrivée d'obama ça à stimuler
une passion électorale et singulièrement
parmi les groupes qui votent et le moins
les noirs américains mais aussi les
aussi les latinos un peu moins chez les
asiatiques les jeunes tous ces groupes
qui jusqu'àlors été les groupes les
moins fiables en termes de participation
et puis les années trump le clivage
extrêmement fort en
2016 on était autour de 60 % en 2020 67%
on n'a jamais vu autant de
participations
[Musique]
certains vont jusqu'à penser que non
seulement la participation n'est pas un
devoir civique mais qu au contraire
l'abstention deviendrait un devoir
citoyen passons par montmorency ou trois
amis évoquent d'entre eux le sujet avec
franchise
[Musique]
tout à l'heure on se disait franchement
t'as vu une différence que ce soit dans
ton quotidien ou dans les gros titres
quand la sarre où il était au pouvoir
qu'en hollande y est de pouvoir la macro
tu vois des grosses différences que ça
dans ton quotidien ou dans le traitement
des par exemple des personnes qui ont
des difficultés franchement c'est vrai
que moi je ne pense pas que la politique
ça sert à rien mais je pense pas non
plus qu'il faut absolument tout misé
dans la politique pour changer le monde
et changer la vie a évidemment les
habitants les entreprises les
associations il ya un tas de gens qui
font qu'on est dans la société dans les
paroles ajourd'hui la base ball à
dresser la politique c'est ces gens qui
vont diriger qui vont tirer les ficelles
oui moi je te dis moi je vote pas ce
seuil avant la qualité que même en
exactement pourquoi on arrive au large
de l'exercice exactement et ça fait
longtemps c'est pour moi simplement oui
pour moi ça fait non mais le magazine le
fait de chirac le pen pour moi ça a été
la dernière heure c'est la seule fois où
j'ai voté dans ma vie et ben moi ça a
été ça qui m'a donné envie de faire
l'apologie et ben moi c'est du sexe m'a
donné envie d'arriver au niveau de vie
des rares sites ailleurs dire que moi en
votant pas tu penses que je suis pas
saine en tout cas tu ne t'inquiète pas
d'un thé devoir de citoyen oui je le
pense oui je pense que ça fait partie de
notre devoir de citoyen d'aller voter ok
c'est ainsi que je me trouve je trouve
que je fais mon devoir de citoyenne de
ne pas aller voter pour justement dire
que je suis contre ce système élitiste
satwa saoud pour te sers pas un argument
valable non pour moi c'est une
efficience si tu considères que le
système politique est mauvais je pense
qu'il faut que tu t'engages en politique
pour changer l'institution ça ce serait
efficace système il est pas bon parce
que des gens travaillent et on s'engage
pas mais je m'engage mais non je
m'engage mais si ça n'engage avant de
l'être je m'engage à pas voter on
voulait est-ce que tu verras qu'un jour
ce qui sait ce qu'ils ne votent pas
comme moi on va un petit peu plus les
prendre en considération
[Musique]
comment réduire l'abstention on a
proposé une véritable boîte à outils
pour faciliter la participation des
citoyens à l'acte électoral
commençons par l'inscription sur les
listes électorales
je rentre le dire que ce n'était pas ça
va la faire avec tu vas la mairie et
oui c'est moi qui fais donc ça c'est
vrai on a eu des cours d'éducation
civique non pas absolument pas ça
on est une des seules grandes
démocraties occidentales a imposé à ses
citoyens encore en 2021 en 2022 de se
déplacer de procéder à une inscription
électorale dans la plupart des autres
pays
l'inscription se fait automatiquement
tout au long de la vie à chaque
déménagement peut-être faut-il trouver
le moyen d'un lien entre déménagement
une démarche administrative qui pourrait
elle-même bénéficié au système électoral
elles sont là le faire automatiquement
mais en toute hypothèse on ne peut pas
laisser les choses en l'état parce que
elle exclut de fait un grand nombre de
nos concitoyens du dispositif de vote
donc il faut modifier ça on peut pas se
satisfaire des situations actuelles pour
supprimer le problème de la malle
inscriptions il faudrait en réalité
rendre cette inscription automatique
pour tous tout au long de la vie c'est à
dire imposer en france une déclaration
domiciliaire obligatoire quand vous
arrivez dans une commune quand vous vous
installez et bien vous êtes
automatiquement inscrits sur les listes
électorales de cette commune ce qui vous
permet de voter le jour du vote à côté
de chez vous sans avoir à penser en
amont à modifier votre inscription
passons au vote par procuration
je pense que facilité de vote par
procuration de ne pose pas de difficulté
dans son principe la question et la
souplesse avec laquelle on peut exercer
ce vote par procuration on a fait des
choses très concrètes on a permis par
exemple que la procuration se fasse en
ligne pour préparer sa demande et que le
passage pour vérifier que les lecteurs
existe parce que sinon vous imaginez les
manipulations soit extrêmement rapide
par exemple dans les commissariats ou
dans l'ensemble des lieux on a eu même
jusqu'à deux procurations par personne
compte tenu de la crise vous avez
autorisé cela et ça a fonctionné plutôt
pas mal d'ailleurs donc c'est une piste
qu'il faut pouvoir
faciliter même si par principe on
préfère toujours le vote personnel à la
dans l'isoloir pour assurer la sécurité
absolue du vote lui-même permettent de
faire une procuration sans se déplacer
physiquement c'est aujourd'hui
impossible dans notre pays ça
permettrait aux jeunes qui n'habitent
plus chez leurs parents et notamment aux
étudiants de voter depuis le lieu où ils
font leurs études et où ils ne sont pas
inscrits sur les listes électorales
maintenant le vote par correspondance
qui a causé tant de polémiques dans la
dernière élection présidentielle
américaine
la plupart du temps là le vote par
correspondance a très bien fonctionné il
ya un certain nombre d'états qui à cause
de la pandémie on dit on ne vote que par
correspondance ça a été par exemple qu'à
en utah l'état de washington
non dans l'ouest ne votent que par
correspondance depuis déjà un ou deux
sites le électoraux donc soit les gens
demandent des bulletins qu'ils reçoivent
chez eux qu'ils mettent à la poste ou
dans des stations des boîtes postales
dédié soit systématiquement les
autorités de l'état envoie des butins à
domicile on sait que la question était
celle du compte et finalement en dépit
de toutes les contestations toutes les
observations ça s'est bien passé
comment fait-on pour assurer la
sincérité du vote pour sécuriser les
bulletins de vote qui serait là à cette
occasion voilà ce sont des questions de
long terme qui doivent être étudiées et
puis par ailleurs ça nécessite des
aménagements dans la loi et là il ya une
loi votée il ya déjà quelques mois pour
l'organisation de l'élection
présidentielle et les parlementaires ont
rejeté ses possibilités à ce moment là
nous sommes réservés
pour des raisons non pas de principes et
de sécurité absolue imaginez qu'on ait
eu un vote par correspondance ou
dernières élections départementales et
régionales compte tenu des difficultés
distribution que nous avons connue ce
soir était un échec encore plus cuisant
en revanche s'impose aussi d'autres
problèmes qui le décalage des jours de
vote en tous les cas un premier tour un
dimanche qu'un deuxième tour une semaine
après s'avère quasiment impossible
compte tenu des délais à respecter
d'envoi des différents des votes de la
sécurité de leur réception et également
de la sécurité du fait de pouvoir
redistribuer ensuite dans les bureaux de
vote donc c'est à dire qu'on modifie
totalement notre usage qui est d'avoir
une élection dans une semaine à dimanche
et le dimanche suivant à l'exception
élection présidentielle le vote par
correspondance et est mis en oeuvre dans
nombre de grandes démocraties voisines
avec un recours de plus en plus
fréquents quand je pense à l'allemagne
notamment il a regardé des citoyens qui
votent aujourd'hui par correspondance ça
se fait sans problème de sécurité
particulier ça se fait en toute
conscience d les lecteurs on ne voit pas
pourquoi il ya une telle réticence avoir
recours vote par correspondance en
france qui encore une fois permettrait à
certaines catégories de la population de
voter facilement ça peut être les
étudiants ça peut être les gens qui sont
isolés qui sont à la campagne les gens
qui sont en vacances qui sont en week
end pourquoi imposer à tous les mêmes
modalités de vote alors qu'on pourrait
cumuler parce qu'il s'agit pas de
substituer une procédure à une autre il
s'agit de d'adapter l'éventail des
manières de voter à la diversité des
situations de nos citoyens sur
l'abaissement du droit de vote à 16 ans
les avis sont partagés
la politologue céline braconnier propose
de l'envisager mais avec une condition
je suis favorable à l'abaissement de
l'âge électoral mais à la condition
qu'ils soient accompagnés d'une vraie
réflexion sur le rôle de l'école dans la
fabrique de la citoyenneté électorale
aujourd'hui il faudrait que l'école ne
soit pas seulement ce lieu
d'apprentissage de la citoyenneté
théorique d'une présentation théorique
des institutions mais soit un lieu
d'accompagnement de des premières
expériences électorales et pour cela il
faudrait que ces expériences est les
lieux plutôt à un âge où on est
davantage scolarisés est à un âge aussi
on est encore en famille et où donc les
parents ont une capacité d'entraînement
plus forte dans la boîte à outils de la
participation électorale il y a aussi
les lits du vote obligatoire compte
essayer entre autres l'australie la
belgique le brésil ou la grèce après dun
côté rendre le vote obligatoire je suis
pas forcément pour mais ça priverait pas
des libertés en fait finalement pas
c'est un peu une liberté de voter quand
même toit que nous on l'entend mais oui
tout le monde ne l'entendrait pas aux
dictatures
il avait par des choses qui sont
obligatoires ont fait c'est ça donne pas
envie de faire parce que dans la trouve
entre confrontation va nous obliger de
faire on va pas le faire justement juste
pour provoquer vaut mieux nous laisser
le choix et nous inciter à voter que
nous obligés parce que ça va pas plaire
aux gens
vote obligatoire c'est une vraie
question en belgique me semble-t-il est
un vote obligatoire la question en
france comme toute obligation c'est si
on a un vote obligatoire quelle serait
la fonction en face façonnons vote moi
j'ai toujours considéré que le vote
c'était un endroit c'est un droit et
c'est aussi un devoir à mon sens et moi
pour tout vous dire je vais je vais
sortir de ma fonction et pour tout vous
dire quand j'entends des gens de me dire
je vais pas voter parce que je préfère
faire autre chose j'ai prévu un pique
nique ou je ne sais quoi je suis
toujours un peu choqué parce que pour
moi c'est en droit et en devoir d'aller
voter et pour moi ça passe avant le
reste comme tout de voir on doit aller
voter et donc maintenant on se met pas
en situation de ne pas être en capacité
de voter le jour du vote si on a
véritablement une obligation que l'on
n'a pas décidé la procuration est
possible et donc l'exercice du droit et
du devoir du jour était possible il ya
une mesure qui ne rencontre pas
l'adhésion des jeunes c'est le vote
obligatoire qui existe dans pas mal
d'autres pays alors là beaucoup de
jeunes de 10 à temps déjà on n'a pas
envie de s'intéresser à la démocratie
alors si en plus vous rendez le vote
obligatoire ça va être contre-productif
de plus en plus la panoplie des mesures
possibles intègre l'idée d'un vote par
internet s'il y avait la possibilité de
voter à distance serait un plus ça peut
être intéressant
ça évite qu'on se déplace et même pour
eux mêmes pas que pour les jeunes les
personnes âgées s'il ne peut pas trop se
déplacer tout bas si l'on quelqu'un pour
les aider peuvent voter directement via
leur téléphone oui ce serait plus facile
c'est sûr mais c'est vrai que enfin
voter c'est quand même mieux en
présentiel fin pour moi sur le
smartphone fin c'est comme s'ils ont
commandé une pizza donc pour moi c'est
quand même assez différent de voter par
téléphone ou par présentiel nous y
arriverons alors
quel est le problème de fond prime de
fond c'est la sécurisation du dispositif
internet du seti numérique ça c'est
fondamental nous savons que nous pouvons
subir des attaques nous savons que pour
avoir des gens qui vont tenter de
modifier les votes il faut aussi assurer
la le vote individuel c'était la
compression et le non-usage
de la peau cité de voter par internet
par d'autres personnes que celui qui
doit le faire si on veut remobiliser une
partie de la population qui n'est pas
sensible au fait d'aller voter à
l'isoloir c'est une hypothèse qu'il faut
vraiment travailler en tous les cas moi
c'est celle que je privilégierai par
rapport à un vote par correspondance
c'est difficile aussi et par internet il
ya des questions numériques et là encore
je ne dis pas que ce n'est pas possible
de faire un vote électronique clic ça
doit être possible mais je pense que si
un jour ça se met en place sur la
volonté du vote des parlementaires il
faudra vraiment réussir à assurer les
conditions matérielles de sécurité
empêcher les piratages empêcher les
cyberattaques assurer là aussi la
sincérité de la personne qui se rend le
contrôle de l'identité de la personne
qui va être rien de tout cela n'est
impossible dans l'absolu mais tout cela
nécessite un vrai travail sérieux je
pense que l'élection saman assez
solennel et je crois pas au vote voyez
comment on serait sur son smartphone et
qu'on choisirait un une veste le ou un
manteau vert je suis la première à
défendre que depuis son smartphone on
puisse faire ses démarches numérique ces
démarches administratives je suis l'ami
nice qui permet aujourd'hui à 30
millions de français de s'identifier
avec un email et un mot de passe unique
par france connect et faire depuis son
smartphone beaucoup de choses mais c'est
une chose de faire des démarches
administratives importantes renouveler
un permis de conduire payer ses impôts à
demander une carte vitale c'en est une
autre pour moi de faire vraiment jouer
son rôle de citoyen doté d'un esprit
critique qui pose un choix qui est au
socle de ce qui fait nation
est il possible de garantir la sûreté
informatique d'un vote électronique
sommes nous suffisamment armé en france
pour affronter ce défi quelles sont les
questions tout sommes allés poser à
nancy l expert que steve kremer
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de système de
vote électronique par internet qui est
aussi sûr que
le système de vote qu'on a dans un
bureau de vote comptines et bien
surveiller donc parce que déjà on est en
train de passer par un vote qui se fait
à distance
donc tout devient plus compliqué comment
est-ce qu'on va authentifier les
personnes comment est ce que je suis sûr
que c'est la bonne personne qui est en
train de voter maintenant en france
effectivement la cnil joue un rôle
important elle donne des recommandations
elle en donne d'ailleurs sur le vote
électronique avec différents niveaux de
certification possible et de façon très
intéressante elle dit que pour l'instant
il affine il déconseille d'utiliser du
vote électronique pour des élections
avec des enjeux forts comme des
élections politiques il ya deux
propriétés fondamentales dans le vote
électronique
le secret du vote comment s'assurer que
mon vote rester anonyme que personne ne
sait comment j'ai voté et puis il ya
évidemment aussi l'intégrité du scrutin
comment je suis sûr que le résultat
annoncé à la fin par un ordinateur et
affectivement le bon et correspond à
tous ascos à ce que les gens ont voté
mais qu'est-ce qui me garantit que
l'ordinateur a bien chiffré le vote que
j'ai bien voulu rentrer donc la silly à
logiciels malveillants il pourrait très
bien remplacer le candidat pour qui j'ai
voté par un autre candidat si c'est une
élection politique
avec un enjeu fort ben là c'est moins
clair qui n'est pas d'adversaire
étatique qui pourrait effectivement qui
a les moyens techniques développées un
malware capable de faire ça donc pour
l'instant on n'a pas de solution qui
effectivement va résoudre tous les
problèmes de sécurité pour des élections
avec un enjeu fort qui arriverait avoir
le même niveau de sécurité que le vote
papier dans un bureau de vote qu'on
connaît
il ya eu un rapport par des collègues
belges qui a étudié cette question et
qui a montré que en fait le fait de
passer en voie telle xtronic votre
région vraiment pas le problème de
l'abstention et de la participation ou
alors vraiment à la marge donc
embarquons pour tallinn la capitale de
l'estonie seul pays de l'union
européenne qui pratiquent le vote par
internet pour toutes ces élections
politiques nous allons découvrir comment
cela se passe concrètement et comment
les estoniens ont réussi à sécuriser ce
vote électronique qui fait encore peur
dans tous nos pays
[Musique]
une chute a indiqué août l'italie ils
furent mobile phones and
[Musique]
computer et de notre connexion avec
hosni dior ait encore d'obtenir nie tout
oui
les buts la semaine verte et nouveaux
titres électroniques cole et sow et
voyages du duo paul coste a toute ses
exploits
de
300 euros bateau
avec
monaco c
est ce qu elle est claire et positive
service aspim good for la 607 has been
good fortement creusé
je me rappelle plus le temps où je me
suis rendu à la station des élections
pour un côté physiquement sur place je
peux pas m'imaginer que j'utilise pas
cette bonne fortune possibilité de
voter électroniquement et en estonie ce
que moi je préférais organisé un dîner
chemin inviter mes amis a dit herman à
l'heure de voter tout le monde doute on
le fait très rapidement et puis on prend
un verre de bière ou de vin on se
félicite de la réussite tant que c'est
une question de style de vie
sain
je connais les années 90 quand il
fallait aller aux urnes j'avoue que j'ai
augmenté le pourcentage de l'abstention
plusieurs fois je ne le changerai jamais
cette
possibilité de voter à
électroniquement contre les que qu'il
faut faire dans les bureaux de vote
faire
ça à la maison la nuit le matin
en buvant le café et je conseillerais
absolument de faire le choix d'
des élections électronique je pense que
ça
diminue certainement l'abstention
retour en france et à nos
abstentionnistes plus précisément à
lille où nous discutons avec quatre
citoyens qui non seulement s'abstiennent
mais anime un groupe qui sur internet
notamment défend et promeut un
abstentionnisme politique
moi je je suis un abstentionniste
convaincu depuis
depuis 2012 donc mon abstention elle est
fondée
essentiellement sur la critique de la
vème république et de son système
électoral que je trouve absolument
antidémocratique donc
pourquoi
j'irais cautionner un système
antidémocratique par un vote on a un
autre exemple le référendum de 2005
c'est hallucinant on a voté non et
finalement il était juge et ça a été oui
la première guerre du golfe je suis
entré chez les communistes et c'est là
que j'ai connu ce que c'était cette
saleté de vote utile parce que j'avais
des copains que tu es coco et qu'il
n'était pas dans le parti j'ai décidé de
rentrer de la même résistance que soit
je ne votais pas ça je voter blanc
sage votes nuls moi ça fait pas si
longtemps que ça en fait
déjà nuit debout ça m'a aidé à réfléchir
au niveau politique j'ai commencé à
comprendre et puis c'est vrai que cette
année là on s'était promis de ne pas
voter et puis moi j'ai failli je suis
quand même allé voter au premier tour je
suis devenu abstentionnistes parce que
en fait je me suis rendu compte par
moi-même en fait
que j'
y avait rien qui me convenait
complètement quoi rien donc je préfère
donc ne pas voter j'ai pas voté les
autres années et
je m'abstiens parce que
tous les personnages pour les types qui
se présentent ne conviennent pas oui
vous êtes des abstentionnistes vous
ouvrez la porte à macron vous ouvrez
vous ouvrez la porte à le pen de toute
façon les abstentionnistes comme nous de
toute façon ils sont méprisés ah oui oh
oui
parce qu'il y en a il y en a un qui qui
nous a sortis
abstention piège à cons néanmoins j'ai
pas dû elle n'a rien mais ouais j'ai pas
envie de voter c'est pas en votant que
on change les choses
exactes
la distance entre les politiques et les
électeurs est devenu tel qu'il ne
suffira pas même si c'est très utile de
mettre en place de nouvelles techniques
pour faciliter la participation
tous nos interlocuteurs nous ont rappelé
que chaque acteur de la vie sociale doit
désormais jouer un rôle dans ce combat
contre l'abstention l'école les parents
les citoyens eux mêmes et puis les
médias la télévision et les réseaux
sociaux et bien sûr les élus et les
partis politiques qui doivent réinventer
les liens de confiance enfin le
fonctionnement même de notre système
montre que la démocratie représentative
a besoin d'être revivifié par une
démocratie plus participative
plus citoyenne
terminons sur ces quelques phrases de
nos grands témoins parce qu'elle met
l'accent sur des pistes de réflexion et
autorise à envisager l'avenir avec plus
d'espoir
on va t ros les jeunes
qu'on leur laisse la réponse libre
indiqué ce qu'il faudrait changer pour
vous soyez plus intéressés par le vote
la première chose qui ressort qui
demande de l'éducation de la pédagogie
être mieux formés mieux équipés mieux
armés pour avoir les clés de leur
engagement dans la démocratie et donc en
en premier les clés du vote donc ça
c'est la première réponse
c'est jamais une chose auquel les
politiques pensent j'ai changé depuis
avec les avec différents professeurs qui
enseignent le mc 10 bah oui mais merci
de mettre ce sujet en avant parce que
nous même par exemple on s'autocensure
beaucoup de professeurs de par le devoir
de neutralité
des agents de l'éducation nationale
n'ose même pas parler de ce qu'est la
gauche de ce qu'est la droite de ce que
sont les feux les forces politiques en
présence donc on va avoir souvent une
approche de la démocratie par l'histoire
de la démocratie ce qui est très
intéressant mais qui ne suffit pas pour
qu'un jeune soit armé pour exercer son
libre choix moi je pense qu'il faut
tabler sur l'éducation à la citoyenneté
et il faut tabler sur voilà la
responsabilité des politiques des
candidats il faut que notre société se
saisissent de cet enjeu qui est la
revivification de la démocratie
représentative
il ya une responsabilité des meilleurs
et ça je le pense je ne sais pas que
tout est la faute des médias mais je
crois qu'il ya aussi une responsabilité
dans la manière dont on amène les choses
je vous donne un exemple en tant que
ministre si je veux aller faire une
interview pour faire un bilan de mon
action ce n'est pas possible les médias
en matinale et en chaîne d'info continue
veulent des annonces donc ils veulent
bien inviter des ministres si vous avez
une annonce à faire si bien que depuis
cinq ans les gens qui ont regardé un
ministre à la télévision l'ont vu dans
90% des cas en situation de faire des
annonces et jamais en situation de faire
un bilan c'est bien qu'il se dise mais
cette annonce d'il ya deux ans mon nez
ou qu'est ce qui a été fait et il est
rare qu'on puisse avoir des occasions
public de dresser le bilan de la non ce
que nous avons fait précédemment vous
savez que la télévision reste le support
essentiel de mobilisation à une élection
présidentielle est évidemment les
réseaux sociaux pour ce qui concerne la
jeunesse donc bien sûr il faut
diversifier aussi les supports de
médiatisation de la campagne non je dis
qu'il ya une responsabilité collective
bah oui il ya une responsabilité des
citoyens qui décident de ne pas aller
voter c'est trop facile là aussi de
considérer que c'est de la faute des
responsables politiques et puis ensuite
il ya forcément une responsabilité des
partis politiques les partis politiques
sont moins attractifs ils ont déçu
peut-être qu'ils ont fait aussi des
promesses qui n'ont pas été en mesure de
tenir une fois qu'ils étaient au
gouvernement ex a éloigné un certain
nombre de personnes de ces partis
policiers croient que beaucoup de partis
politiques depuis des décennies ou père
du fils avec les français parce qu'ils
n'ont pas réussi à rendre tangible dans
la vie quotidienne des français au fond
les promesses qu'il faisait on peut
changer toutes les règles du monde
si les élus eux mêmes c'est nous-mêmes
j'en fais partie naturellement ne sommes
pas en capacité d'aller à la rencontre
de nos concitoyens pour les intéressés
c'est peut-être bien de notre première
responsabilité
je crois que ça tient d'abord à une
capacité des candidats des élus a
intéressé et surtout sans doute à
rétablir la confiance et la confiance
c'est d'abord le langage de vérité pour
moi la politique c'est pas du théâtre
c'est pas de divertissement c'est pas
une succession d'événements dont on voit
d'ailleurs souvent les français se
détournent moi je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de parler aux français comme si
c'était des enfants on n'est pas là pour
faire de la pédagogie sur nos réformes
n'est pas la peur de la pédagogie sur la
politique ou la pédagogie sur les
élections on est là pour recréer avec
eux rien de suffisamment fort de preuves
la pédagogie des preuves des preuves que
voter
amène au pouvoir des hommes et des
femmes qui agissent et qui agissent de
manière suffisamment tangible pour que
vous voyez là où vous êtes une
différence est que vous puissiez juger
de cette différence ce qui change c'est
quoi c'est que les jeunes
la pole pour eux la politique des plus
dans le vote la politique est résident
dans l'action citoyenne au quotidien
donc ils n'attendent plus du politique
il faut s'engager eux mêmes ça pose
quand même des questions puisque on se
dit finalement la somme de toutes ces
actions individuelles c'est peut-être
très bien mais un moment donné il faut
fédérer il faut trouver un commun pour
pouvoir faire avancer les choses et je
pense que c'est toute la question des 10
15 voire 20 prochaines années essaie de
comprendre comment cette jeunesse
engagée peut encore faire de
société et peut encore faire une
politique au sens collective du terme
donc on est à un moment je crois de
bascule soit on bascule vers une
meilleure connexion des citoyennes et
des citoyens notre vie politique c'est
tout les nouveaux outils démocratiques
de démocratie participative mais où on
tient compte de ce que les gens disent
dans la décision publique et je crois
qu'on est vraiment à un moment de
bascule parce que les gens ne veulent
plus être enfumé à un moment c'était la
démocratie représentative
les élus décident pour les citoyens
aujourd'hui on doit être dans une
combinaison entre la démocratie
représentative
ce qu'on fait ici à l'assemblée ce qui
est fait au sénat et la démocratie
participative et c'est sur l'interaction
de ces deux formes de démocratie que se
joue l'avenir de la démocratie notre
pays c'est la passion qui fait voter
visiblement il ya des hommes qui suscite
la passion il ya des programmes qui
suscitent la révolte c'est aussi une
passion est au fond le juste milieu
l'inflexion mais pas révolutionnaire
ça suscite une forme d'indifférence
[Musique]